dans cet hôpital de la banlieue de
buenos aires est ce le ballet des
patients atteints du cobp hiddink est
incessant la semaine dernière plus de
122 mille nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés dans le pays une nouvelle
flambée poussant le président alberto
fernandez a renforcé les mesures de
restriction dans la région
métropolitaine de buenos et rs6 j'ai
décidé de restreindre les déplacements
nocturnes entre 20h et 6h du matin de
20h à 6h il ne sera pas possible de
circuler dans les rues et les poètes et
j'ai ordonné la suspension de toutes les
activités récréatives sociale culturelle
sportive et religieuse menée dans des
lieux fermés
ces mesures comprennent également la
suspension des écoles pendant deux
semaines et à partir de lundi les cours
se feront virtuellement
mercredi dernier le président argentin
avait déjà annoncé l'interdiction de
circuler dans les grands centres urbains
entre minuit et 6 heures du matin ainsi
que la fermeture des discothèques et des
lieux festifs mais pour la population
le problème réside essentiellement dans
les transports publics des transports
publics surpeuplé où la distanciation
social est impossible à respecter même
sur les quais des trains et pourtant des
agents sont en théorie chargée de
vérifier sa bonne tenue et de contrôler
les usagers en vérifiant qu'il s'agit
bien de travailleurs dits essentiels
seuls autorisés normalement à prendre
les transports
les gens ont besoin de travailler car
sinon de quoi vivrions nous ils n'ont
pas assez à manger pour leurs enfants et
même si tu tombes malade les hôpitaux
sont un désastre il n'y a pas de place
la vérité c'est que j'ai peur il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de gens
les contrôles ne sont pas là ils vous
disent attestation en main mais il ne la
regarde pas je comprends que nous avons
tous besoin de travailler mais nous
voyageons dans de mauvaises conditions
il y a beaucoup de gens vraiment
beaucoup de gens un surpeuplement qui
s'explique en partie par le fait que
seulement 85 % des bus de buenos aires s
sont en circulation selon le ministère
des transports un écart qui s'explique
par le nombre de chauffeurs atteint par
le coronavirus et qui n'ont pu être
remplacés